as I mentioned I'm diabetic and one
things that I noticed in my dad before
he knew he was diabetic he had come home
from the train at night and my sister
and I would rub his legs because they
hurt this is one of the problems with
diabetics his feet hurt and I remember
my sister Nancy saying once gee daddy
smells like mommy's nail polish remover
which was acetone okay and acetone is
one of the three ketone bodies the other
two being beta-hydroxybutyrate acid and
acetoacetate so what happens in diabetes
is you know the diabetic doesn't have
ample carbohydrate reserves within their
cells as glycogen so they're you doing a
lot of fatty acid oxidation rather than
carbohydrate metabolism if you take a
fatty acid and you break it down to ask
the Toa
the last steps called beta kita thiolase
backs up then your two carbons of acetic
away will be four carbons of
acetoacetate and then that acetoacetate
a third acetic we can add to it to form
what's called hydroxymethyl glute a real
coenzyme a okay hmg-coa and then
rearrangements can happen they give rise
altum Utley to the to the three ketone
bodies acetoacetate beta hydroxy
butyrate and acetone so in situations
where of starvation and diabetes is
basically my cells we're in a technical
state of starvation in a case of
starvation what happens is you you're
you get this backup of the lipid
breakdown or catabolism pathway and then
these ketone bodies flush out into your
blood in starvation situations the
ketone bodies will act as fuels for your
your your brain and other organs it's a
it's a difficult transition but ketone
bodies are are in the case of diabetics
they're produced to access to such a
stand
that they're they're actually quite
harmful to you the reason a person
smells of acetone is the intermediate
ketone body the acetoacetate basically D
carboxylates it's a beta keto acid and
so it's a spontaneous decomposition to
form acetone acetone is not to my
knowledge
biochemically useful as a kind of an
energy source but it's a sentinel or
it's something that is smelled so that
it can be diagnostic of the disease